[Applaudissements]
encore ça boit ça fait pas rire et je
vois cette huile est il honnête bojan il
le dit moi je pense qu'il ya plus de
gens comme ça de ce qu'on pense oui là
tous des gens que on n'a jamais eu une
histoire exact que ce qu'on pense que
c'est comme ça
oui merci et merci rafael nadal lé
marois bas kate a commenté roy pas foule
à disjoncter shopix iphone ou tout
appareil ou tout non mais oui c'est tout
excessif mais mes parents il est quand
même chaud faut faire gaffe avec lui à
mon avis non bien sûr il est il est
quand même chose
d'origine espagnole quoi cette d'origine
espagnole oui c'est ça prend c'est
bizarre mais je parle espagnol
j'aime bien parce que le gars en clair
un accent espagnol est situé par
l'espagnole seat